“Sinus suffering.”
On the left is a decongestant commercial
from 2000.
On the right one from 2006.
But don't focus on the pressure pads
or exploding heads.
Look at the boxes.
Sudafed and Sudafed PE.
PE.
Sudafed usually uses pseudoephedrine.
Sudafed PE stands for phenylephrine.
Today, phenylephrine vastly outsells
pseudoephedrine.
Yet, I am still congested.
I was popping one of these daily
in the morning, every morning...
and it just didn't work.
But it's not me and it's not you.
That's because...
“This drug is really not effective.”
“10 milligrams of phenylephrine
works no better than a placebo.”
“Now, there are serious questions
about whether it works at all.”
Taken from an FDA Zoom meeting
these are the votes of FDA panel members
on whether phenylephrine is effective.
“Yeah, I voted no.”
“I voted no.”
“-I voted no.”
“The data are pretty clear.”
How did this happen?
It is a story that goes back decades
and touches on methamphetamine,
COVID...
and most importantly
why you were able to buy
a decongestant...
that didn't work.
[dramatic cello music]
Imagine a grocery store.
The FDA regulates food over here...
and the prescription drugs over here.
These are both massive jobs.
And a separate FDA job is here:
The over-the-counter drugs: OTC.
Available for anyone to just buy
and walk out.
And that is what I have been buying.
[curious piano music]
In 1962, the federal government
charged the FDA with a new responsibility:
Instead of just regulating the sale of drugs...
they had to start reviewing
the safety and effectiveness of them.
They started here, in the prescription section...
because they were more worried about it.
Ten years later, they got to
the OTC drugs.
This proposal outlined the plan.
But this shelf was big.
100,000 to 500,000 products, big.
And it was too much to thoroughly
work through.
Well, I think people perceive...
that because something sold
over the counter...
it has been reviewed more rigorously,
but that is just not true.
A lot of the products and the research
dates back decades.
That's Joshua Sharfstein.
He is a professor, but also a former...
principal deputy commissioner at the FDA.
He helped take over-the-counter
cough and cold medicines
off the market for kids
back in the early 2000s.
But in the 70s and 80s
the FDA said that drug ingredients
already on the shelf...
could stay if they were generally recognized
as safe and effective by medical professionals.
By 1976, they'd convened a looser review
and a panel recommended Phenylephrine
as an oral, nasal decongestant.
They also recommended phenylpropanolamine
and pseudoephedrine.
We’ll make phenylephrine red...
because we know it leaves you congested.
Like me.
Pseudoephedrine and blue,
because it does work.
And phenylpropanolamine grey.
I'll tell you why later.
This list of nasal decongestants
still mostly grandfathered in...
was further codified by the 1990s.
So you had options on the shelf,
sold under many names...
and pseudoephedrine became
the OTC nose-unclogger of choice
through the 80s and 90s.
And that was kind of the status
quo with commercials like these:
“Feel well enough to get married, honey?”
“I do.”
“Fast-acting Sudafed and long-lasting
Sudafed 12 hour.”
“Take non-drowsy Sudafed at your first sign.”
“Fight back with Sudafed.”
But then... this happened.
“Pseudoephedrine, a common ingredient
in cold medicines like Sudafed
is an essential part of
making methamphetamine.”
“In response to that, Congress in 2005
enacts the Combat Methamphetamine Act.”
If you need it clearer, imagine Walt and Jesse
from Breaking Bad
crushing up pseudoephedrine to make meth.
This law, tacked on to the Patriot Act...
largely meant pseudoephedrine
decongestants
were put behind the counter.
In many states, you could buy it
without a prescription...
but you had to be ID'd by a pharmacist...
and were limited in how much you could get.
“I mean, it's getting harder
and harder to come by.”
Phenylpropanolamine was generally considered
unsafe by 2000...
because it caused some hemorrhagic strokes.
Phenylaphrine was alone on the shelf.
Meth-finding officials asked
companies like Pfizer:
“What took so long?”
But the FDA's long process meant
they couldn't just spin up a new product.
Commercials started to look like this:
“The new Sudafed PE
Triple Action.”
“Also find Sudafed behind the counter.”
But even as manufacturers
tried to straddle the lines,
phenylaphrine sales...
this line, started to beat out this line:
pseudoephedrine decongestants.
Basically because it was alone on the shelf.
Now, you probably saw this recent story
about the FDA panel
recommending against phenylephrine
and assumed that they just figured out
that it didn't work.
That is not the case.
They have known for decades
that phenylephrine might not really work...
and it's just the process
that's gotten in the way.
“Sudafed’s replacement no winner”
was a 2006 headline as the key.
As the key researchers behind that report
recalled on the panel this year...
After pseudoephedrine was removed
in front of the counter
to behind the counter...
I received a rash of calls from
around the state of Florida...
asking why oral Phenylephrine didn't work.
The take home messages are oral
phenylephrine is inaffective
as a nasal decongestant but safe.
They found that most of the studies
ruling it effective
came from one lab:
Elizabeth Biochemical.
The researchers letter to the FDA from 2006
attracted congressional support...
from Representative Henry Waxman.
It led to further similarly conclusive studies...
that phenylephrine was ineffective.
So why has it stayed on the shelf
for almost two more decades?
“We'll hear from Dr. Janet Woodcock
director of the FDA's Center for
Drug Evaluation and Research.”
Dr. Janet Woodcock shared this list of burdensome...
multi-step rule makings that were typical
for new drugs or revisions to old ones.
“This process is frozen in 1972 and before...
so it doesn't apply to anything later than that.”
“So, this is only still trying to deal
with those products
that were on the market at that time.”
“So, there's really nothing for innovation
in this entire process.”
That matched with significantly smaller
funding for
the FDA's over-the-counter division
versus the prescription drug one.
It took until the 2020 CARES Act,
a Coronavirus relief bill...
to make the drug slightly easier to amend...
and to give the FDA's over-the-counter division
a bit more funding.
The FDA had its hands...
tied behind its back when thinking
about over-the-counter medicines,
and now it has more tools
and more resources to go about its job.
And in 2023, the advisory panel
finally reviewed new studies
filled with charts like these.
Where nasal congestion went down
after taking pseudoephedrine...
and went like this for a placebo...
and phenylephrine.
Now we wait.
It is true that all this time
I could have gone behind the counter
and had pseudoephedrine,
been less congested.
But I didn't know there was anything wrong
with phenylephrine.
The advisory panel vote...
that spreadsheet is a recommendation
that the FDA still has to act on
and implement.
And the panelists voting,
they seemed a little mystified
by how we got to a point where
phenylephrine took over.
It's amazing the amount of dollars
being spent on something
that has really no efficacy.
I went through pharmacy school
and medical school
and I have taken courses on
over-the-counter medications...
and I had no idea until prepping for this
how limited the data was.
The drug companies have made billions of dollars...
off of this medication.
You know, for all these years.
You know, people really don't like change.
And this is going to change.
You know, how the oh, according cost aisle
look in the you know,
in the pharmacy.
That does not suggest in any way...
that they should not stay the course.
I miraculously healed.
Okay.
My name is Phil Edwards.
I'm the producer of this episode.
I'm doing culture coverage.
You've seen the awesome looking
slate at the beginning.
We're defining culture really broadly.
We're going to be talking about
all sorts of different things...
that kind of effect the way
that we live.
I have one quick request for you before we go.
Here at Vox...
you know, our mission is to have...
our journalism be free to everybody.
We don't want to put it behind the counter.
That's a little callback to the video for you.
We don't want to have a paywall.
We don't want to do it.
It's just not a value that the company has
and that we have as part of the larger companies.
Sometimes our work is supported
by advertising
but it's not enough.
We need a little extra push to get us
over the hump.
And so that's why we're looking to you.
If you can help keep our journalism free and support...
our more ambitious work,
go to www.vox.com/give-now
to make a contribution.
Your contributions support
all our coverage across Vox
and as a thank you to those of you
who make recurring contributions
we will give you access to newsletters,
behind-the-scenes, Q&A
with journalists from across
the whole Vox newsroom.
All right.
Thanks for watching.
Bye.